is the chemistry behind this color
changing blush it has a chemical inical
red 27 which is the same dye that's in
color changing lipstick sister can take
on true forms it's colorless when it's
intact which is when it's dry or below
pH 2.5 but when it's dissociated it
turns pink and this happens when it's
wet or above pH 2.5 this color changing
blush has a water free formula so when
water from your skin wets it there's
lots of water in your skin it goes pink
so it doesn't really adjust based on
your skin pH it's still changing color
above ph4 your skin is above that and it
doesn't really adjust to your skin tone
apart from the fact that it's sheer so
you can see your skin through it it's
just adjusting to how wet your face is
and because there's only really one die
that does this this blush and color
changing lipsticks only come in one
shade